his company which is called tiny which
buys businesses it's going public and
Andrew owns roughly 71 percent of the
shares and it's going public at a nearly
billion dollar valuation who knows what
it's going to actually trade at but if
it trades out what they wanted to trade
at that's about 700 to 800 million
dollars that Andrew will have from all
starting with a bootstrap agency and I
want to walk through his journey and I
think this is amazing it's pretty
mind-blowing
[Music]
foreign let's do it I'm um fancy shirt
fancy shirt
all I gotta say is fancy shirt I now do
this thing where if somebody does
anything that's like I feel like they
left the house today feeling good about
that or they you know they got a haircut
I'm not subtle about it I'll just I act
like a like a dog barking I'm just like
nice haircut you got you you changed
your face
the thing that the audience is gonna
call me out on is I I couldn't find my
other glasses do I have to wear these
glasses the problem with them is that
[__] Jeffrey Dahmer decided to wear
the same ones yeah so it looks like I'm
gonna ask you like do you want to come
back to the apartment to take some
tasteful pictures and have some beers
like they'll be real nice like that he
ruined it for me some people are into
that I have a meaty one another publicly
traded company this is a big deal and it
kinda has not been made a big deal in
the media because
it's I guess not that big a deal to them
it's a billion dollar company but
basically our friend Andrew Wilkinson
friend of the Pod friend of ours we're
going to be with him in Vancouver on
February 16th so if you want to come see
us uh live
he basically
and by the way I got a preference this
now that he's a publicly traded company
everything that I'm going to say I just
Googled it this is all just from Google
I didn't ask him anything and a lot of
it's guesses but not all of it he
basically had a company that was
publicly traded called we Commerce and
it was not doing great it like peaked at
like 500 million went down to 80 million
anyway he's doing a reverse takeover no
sorry he's doing a merge and he's his
company which is called tiny which buys
businesses it's going public and Andrew
owns roughly 71 of the shares and it's
going public at a nearly billion dollar
valuation who knows what it's going to
actually trade at but if it trades out
what they wanted to trade at that's
about 700 to 800 million dollars that
Andrew will have from all starting with
a bootstrap agency and I want to walk
through his journey and I think this is
amazing it's pretty mind-blowing okay
the by the way the billion dollars is
this uh one problem by the way is that
all of his numbers were in Canadian
dollars it was all CAD instead of USD so
is this a billion CAD or is this a
billion USD everything I'm gonna say is
Canadian and I don't know what the
conversion rate is of Monopoly money to
USD but like it's it's somewhere close
enough that we're still in the same
ballpark yeah so I think it's I think
it's a little bit more like 700 million
is the the number that basically just
discounted something like 20 30 yeah
Andrews and CAD is Canadian Andrews and
Canada if you ever really want to
inflate something right like if you're
five nine
you're you're 511 CAD so just just go
Cad and you'll you know get that extra
get that little extra that you feel
you've been missing your whole life
so dude this story it's really
impressive Andrew comes on the Pod and
we mess with them but like this is we
treat him like he's one of us
what he's pulled off is like not one of
us man it's pretty epic he's actually
more like 20 of us
he's the Brian scalabrini of Rich guys
you know what I mean like this is the
skellage he's the worst billionaire I
know but he's the best millionaire I
know yeah for sure I mean he's killing
it so listen to this so basically the
company that is taking public at this
point has and this now this stuff is
actually uh public uh it's doing about
150 million in Revenue 50 million in
ebitda and so here's the story so 2006
Andrew was I think 19. he started a web
design agency called meta lab and meta
lab is like the core of all this in year
one it had 250 000 in revenue and
basically what he's doing is he's doing
like design stuff so one of his big
famous clients was before slack was
slack Stuart Butterfield he you know
reached out to Andrew said hey help me
design slack and like I don't know it's
web interfacing which frankly I don't
even know entirely the the whole scope
of that work but like more than logos
but including logos I believe right
more than logos that should be their
tagline no it was definitely we draw
good
we draw good plus more logos and more uh
no it was it was web interfacing so it
was actually fairly technical but in
year one it did too 250 000 in Revenue
with a 50 profit margin in the year uh
2019 so three years in it was doing
about a couple hundred thousand in
profit and it doubled uh for a couple
years and then grew by 30 a year so 2012
you're six years in only three million
in Revenue not like right crazy out of
this league like you know he's he's kind
of like what people say about us is
you're relatable and whatever people say
that I was like
you're so authentic you're so relatable
I'm like what I like about you guys is
you're not successful yeah and you're
pretty dumb so it just feels good you
guys yeah and so that's exactly how I
feel so he was relatable so in year six
three million in Revenue but after that
it grows 30 a year which but which if
you add up 30 annual growth by 2020
you're at something like 20 million in
Revenue by 2023 you're in like the 40 or
50 range and the reason why Andrew's
agency works so well is and I actually
think this won't work this doesn't work
as much anymore is he's based out of
Victoria uh I don't even I'm such I'm so
ignorant I don't even know what state
Providence Minnesota but a little higher
yeah yeah yeah
he's in like yeah he's in like the Boise
of Canada yeah upper Idaho I guess
foreign
[Music]
have you heard of HubSpot see most trms
are a cobble together mess but HubSpot
is easy to adopt and actually looks
gorgeous I think I love our new CRM our
software is the best HubSpot grow better
and so what that means is he's paying
those wages but he's charging Silicon
Valley pre British Columbia Ben just
corrected me there you go British
Columbia whatever that is uh I don't
know what pset is on the Monopoly board
but it's somewhere around there and so
he's charging Silicon Valley prices to
like the slacks of the world so these
high-end prices but he's paying Canadian
wages so that margin is fat and so
that's why he's able to take make all
this uh profit and he starts taking his
profit and he starts launching companies
and it doesn't work so well he launches
one little software company uh I forget
what it was called flow I think it was
basically like an a Sonic competitor
doesn't work out he's like I invested
too much money goes
[__] this what if I just buy a company
he reads a book on Warren Buffett and
he's like yeah yeah I could do this and
that's his new hero he turns into a
buffet guy and he starts buying
businesses and he buys a couple that are
doing okay but then he buys one that
becomes like the Crown Jewel this whole
business so this whole thing tiny
there's I think there's two crown jewels
there's meta lab which we can guess is
doing 40 or 50 million in Revenue 20
million in profit that's the cash flow
engine of this whole thing of being able
to buy these companies then he buys uh
dribble which is basically like GitHub
for designers so designers go to this
website
and they upload their portfolios other
people can share your portfolio you send
it to employers they can comment you get
inspiration whatever now I don't have
all the details on this but I if I had
to guess dribble was launched by two
Founders who weren't very business savvy
and it had a lot of traffic but they're
like dude we don't know how to like make
money off this and Andrew buys it from
them I imagine if I had a guess I bet
you he buys it for five to ten million
dollars
turns this thing into a behemoth making
now it's making many tens of millions of
dollars if I had to guess it's worth
200 million dollars or higher I'm this
is just pure guess
and that becomes a crown jewel of this
company tiny and so now he's got these
two agencies or a meta lab and dribble
and then he also has now what do they
own like 15 other companies and he's
taking it public and throughout this
whole period he's bootstrapping this
thing So Meta lab is the one that's
paying for everything he's hires a CEO
to run meta lab and because of that he
basically owns like 90 of meta lab and
now he owns what did I say 70 of these
tiny shares and then his other partner
in the business owns like 10 so him and
Chris is his partner own 80 of this
publicly traded company that's hoping to
go public in the billion dollar range
this is just a crazy fascinating story
and uh I can't believe he's pulled this
off
yeah I got to be careful what I say
because I invested in tiny recently when
it was Private
um so I kind of know more of the numbers
but I don't know what's public versus
what was Private am I the ballpark of
everything
yeah I think you're in the ballpark
um I think the maybe the dribble
valuation maybe a little bit High
um but you're right that those two
things make up like you know
It's like because I guess here's my
here's where this kind of broke for me
and this is maybe not that interesting
just my personal framework broken a good
way in a good way which was uh I thought
he'd been around doing this for way
longer it was actually 2016 when he
started like
buying other companies and um
that's not that long ago like we we met
him in I don't know I met him in I want
to say 2020. you know that's only four
years in and it was but I would note
about him he was like a personality yeah
exactly like he always had this like
cool looking Avatar his pictures always
look cool he was like a designer so his
hair was always slicked back and he had
this like where we all looked like dorks
he was like kind of good looking in his
pictures and stuff like that yeah it
just shows what a good head of hair
could do for you and um you know I think
that's the real takeaway number one
um number two number two this segment is
brought to you by hymns number three uh
no so so I think that that was the first
thing which was wow this was actually
built up in a a relatively like on one
hand it's a long period of time because
he's been started metal lab a long time
ago so that part you got to give credit
for the oh wow 2006 and then he grinded
it out year after year building the
service business up but on the other
hand the portfolio side of things was
relatively new so I thought that was
really interesting the second thing
I assumed that the portfolio was a lot
more a lot flatter a lot more parody so
maybe like
there were
um you know five to ten companies all of
sort of equal value pitching in each one
like you know five to ten percent of the
overall value of the pie and that's how
you get like you know 70 or something
like that and the rest is meta lab and
in fact it was kind of like like a
venture portfolio in a way where a
couple of the companies were really the
standout ones that were driving most of
the value and I think for them it was
actually three there was the the one
they took they originally took public so
we Commerce which is basically their
Shopify apps roll up uh so the Shopify
app roll-up I think was was one winner
dribble is another winner in meta Labs
another winner and to me
everything else is nice but now that
those are such big Winners that they
make up so much revenue and so much
ebitda that the others are almost like
rounding errors at the moment uh that's
a little bit harsh I would say but you
know so maybe that's maybe that's a
little too harsh but
just comparatively it wasn't like this
portfolio of a dozen equally sized
companies
um which maybe was I never should have
assumed that in the first place but when
you hear somebody's doing a portfolio
you sort of think okay it's going to be
sort of more smoothly distributed out
but but it was actually a little bit
more concentrated in a few key key
winners that just really kept
compounding at a high rate and um so
yeah so I think that's that's amazing I
think what he's done is amazing like um
to build this level of a of a sort of
empire in this short of amount of time
is uh it's pretty awesome and the
biggest thing is I love that he did it
his way like there really wasn't
anybody doing
exactly what he was doing
um of course there's private Equity
right but he wasn't doing it like
private Equity because he wasn't looking
to flip he's looking to buy and hold so
then you have sort of okay okay who's
doing permanent Equity who's doing a buy
and hold strategy okay there's some
people doing it but they all raised
money he used his own company's profits
to do it so that's pretty dope and then
he branded it and was more public about
it versus these kind of more under the
radar it's like oh you you're part of
like Maple Oak Capital what is that you
know I go to your website it's got two
lines it just says we acquire software
companies and it's like okay I I don't
know what this means whereas he built
kind of like a sexy brand out of it so I
think there was a bunch of things he did
that were pretty cool like even his term
sheet he's like oh I read that Warren
Buffett basically you know we'll meet a
company understand it and then write a
one sheet a one-page you know like term
sheet for them to just you know are they
gonna take this deal or not he doesn't
do this like complicated lawyer process
if he can buy a billion dollar company
with with a one or two pager then I
should be able to buy
this three million dollar company with a
one-pager and so he took you know he
took that approach and I think did a
good job branding what he was doing
along the way
yeah and so here's a few more takeaways
and then I want to hear yours uh if you
have any extra ones the first is that
you said that he did this quickly yeah
kinda but he also did it really slowly
the Acquisitions part only yeah the
acquisition part but he basically
started in 2006 and then he didn't
really hit his stride until 2016. so
that's 10 years of having an agency now
he didn't run the agency the whole time
he ran up for a little while and then he
also hired people and so I'm I'm sure he
was managing it to some extent but slow
is good in some cases and the second
thing is that he didn't raise money for
an agency and because of that he had so
much Freedom the second you raise money
that that your cap table is one of the
few things that you can't reverse or
it's really hard and he didn't raise
money for a company that meta Labs
should not have raised money and it did
not raise money and because of that he
was able to use the profits to invest in
[__] versus if you raise money they're
like no don't use those profits to do
other things reinvest them and make this
thing bigger the next thing is financial
maneuvering
like you know I joke that I like don't
know anything about finances it's kind
of uh like his like thing I think I
think he's built that skill up over time
right didn't didn't know it initially
but but yeah has he can create a lot of
value a lot of people do this now they
can create a lot of value by increasing
their financial IQ like
um taking we Commerce public via SPAC in
2020 when the timing was perfect
um required some combination of being
prepared with a good business secondly
uh you know identifying the timing and
saying now is the time go aggressively
and third is like just having the
financial IQ to go with the balls to be
able to actually go pull something like
that off 100 the next thing is where you
live it can actually matter a lot now I
think that this gap of Silicon Valley
wages and Victoria Canada wages might be
closed a little bit it's closer at least
than it was before that Gap is smaller
but this still exists in other places I
know I have friends that have built
pretty big businesses are building them
right now noun they're using Indian
Talent versus American talent and
they're getting great products so you do
with this podcast
[Laughter]
guilty
and then the final thing is hiring and
negotiating the way he negotiated with
his CEOs and kept them happy while also
retaining Equity so I don't know like
how he pays people I I imagine he pays
them with just tons of cash
so that's like you're like well that's
easy you just pay over pay people but
anyway it's still like really impressive
I was able to negotiate and hire and
manage people I've heard from a bunch of
his CEOs where they're like when things
are going fine I don't ever hear from
them and I love that and then of course
I imagine there's times when things
aren't going fine he's like all right
dude come on we gotta we gotta like push
this a little harder but he's done a
really good job of hiring and uh anyway
this whole thing that he's pulled off
I messaged him and I was like this
sounds like an insult yeah we gotta clap
we'll clap for him I was like dude this
sounds like it this sounds like an
insult but do you ever just sit with
like a shit-eating grin and just laugh
at like a little evil laugh and be like
got him I pulled off this paper because
that's kind of what it feels like
because
he makes it look easy and of course it's
never easy there's like there's times
where he'll message me he's like dude I
feel like I'm in the dumps or I feel
overwhelmed he's human but he's done a
really good job of doing it his way
almost to the point where I'm like dude
you got to be smirking right now like
it's that feeling like when you get
successful and you think of all your
ex-girlfriends who like made fun of you
it's like you you [__] it
you have with like the names of all your
enemies marked on like champagne bottles
do you like when you pop that cork off
whatever you like a lock of their hair
and you just set it a fire with the
lighters yeah dude what are you talking
about
but he's pulled it off he's let me let
me let me also say another thing
you know that
um there are people that are masters of
engineering you know people that are um
you know fantastic leaders
but you know I'm the dawn of
Storytelling and Andrew is a great
Storyteller so people should go read his
dribble 2.0 blog post it's on medium so
uh just Google dribble 2.0 Andrew
Wilkinson
and here okay Sam how do most people
announce an acquisition
um go just just uh give me your generic
thing yeah it's like uh we're so bra we
are so we're so so we're so pleased they
built a really nice business and we're
happy to be stewards of this business
and we're really looking forward to the
future and then like the sellers like
you know we were looking for a nice home
Foreigner and we're excited for the
future just nonsense no absolute
absolute soulless dribble so here's
here's what he he didn't said so here's
I'm just gonna read a little snippet of
this because I think
people should pick up on the
storytelling too I think that helps so
he goes when I first started meta lab
Dan cedarholm was my hero
a great opening line a great one because
I don't know who this guy is and now I'm
like why is this person your hero he
goes this bulletproof web was the first
book I read I used to reverse engineer
his style sheets on simple bits to learn
his CSS tricks anything he did I did and
I drove my front end developers nuts
trying to get them to implement every
little one pixel detail that I learned
from Dan so already you're like okay
this is interesting he's basically
setting the context of like that's the
guy who started dribble and he's like
it's not just I bought dribble and I'm
pleased to to you know raise prices in
six months he's like you know I uh I've
admired this guy this guy's my hero I
learned from him and so when he uh so
here so let me uh keep going so he goes
I remember I remember meeting another
favorite designer Dave Dave Shea at a
conference back in 2008. he mentioned
that he knew Dan my floor my jaw Hit the
Floor wait what the CSS drop Shadows the
cork logo he's the best what's he like I
was gushing
um blah blah
I wasn't just a fanboy I was his web
standards Fanboy uh blah blah blah then
he keeps going he goes one of the
projects that Dan did was dribble which
he co-founded with whoever uh I had used
it blah blah blah which is why I'm
excited I'm saying I'm excited to share
the big news right so just that little
paragraph of setup
it draws you in in a way that like he
could have just done a standard boring
eye roll press release and instead he
decided to do it this way and then he he
talks about kind of like that it wasn't
just like therefore we've acquired it
and it's done he's like I was bugging
him and bugging him I kept emailing them
every month asking them if they would
let me in he's like this September my
Moxie finally paid off he emailed me
saying they would think to do they might
do it they cared about these three
things I wouldn't mess it up I have a
long-term View and I want them to stay
involved and own a piece of the business
we shook hands and made a deal
um blah blah blah and then he tells the
rest of the you know then he then he
does the standard stuff about we're
excited it's going to be great and um I
just thought that was just a way better
way of doing it than the average person
would do it and if you add up a lot of
doing things better than the average
person would do it you end up with this
type of exceptional outcome
it it's just great man I I have a lot of
respect from them there there's always
like this little bit of Envy in me uh
when I talk to Andrew because he's my
friend and uh I consider us peers and
but then then he'll make jokes about
like what he's doing on the weekend and
then like oh that's sick and uh and then
but I'm proud of him I feel like I feel
I feel a lot of Pride like on his full
kind of for him and I'm very happy that
he's pulled this off and I think it's
really impressive and I think that it's
badass that people are that there are
people that are bold enough to do things
their way regardless of what the Nerds
invest in from Stanford tell you the way
you should do it and I imagine that
along the way he got a lot of flack
making fun of him from being in Canada
uh for not raising money for buying
these little quote little things and I
guess that's the [__] name of the
company tiny but he just like pulled it
off and I appreciate that gumption and I
appreciate that boldness and I find it
inspiring and I'm happy that like we
have him in our life so that's my little
love note to Andrew good job love letter
to Andrew Wilkinson yeah
and if you wanna we're going to Canada
we're going to be there February 16th
and Andrew if you're listening to this
you want to fly us up there private
that's cool if you want to celebrate we
know how much money you have now so yeah
look let's celebrate my favorite one
friend invite another over yeah yeah
let's celebrate by flying private
together except
we'll be like you don't have to be there
and Sean and I will each be in different
planes uh
so can we have an allowance can you just
send us a card with just an allowance
that would be tight
um anyway that's my breakdown of tiny he
deserved it
dude I got roasted so badly by my
daughter uh last night I was like oh man
this is your four-year-old daughter
arrested you so badly nice three three
years old we played so so she she can't
play mini games we play
um rock paper scissors but she always
throws scissors so that's like you know
fun for for her not for me
um she plays hide and seek always hides
in the same spot that's why kids do this
they just like play the game but they
don't know how to play and then she so
that so I taught her I Spy I was like oh
here's a game we could play in the car
um I spy and so she loves I spy so she
so I'm like I spy something green she's
like is it the tree I'm like how'd you
get it it's almost the tree that's right
and she goes I spy something yellow and
I'm like looking around the house I'm
like what is it yellow I don't see
anything yellow she goes your teeth
it's gonna she's not aware that that's
the sickest burn and that anybody's here
to anybody hey I smile an [__] yeah
exactly I was like wow that is just like
natural that's a natural burn
can I tell you about something cool that
you probably know about and I saw it and
I can't stop thinking about it have you
heard of the scallenge
I don't know about this tell me about
this all right this is you know I don't
pay attention to sports this is your
league so uh you know you know Brian is
Brian oh oh scalabrini okay I didn't
know he called it the scallenge that's a
good name well explain who he is people
don't know probably so Brian uh
scalabrini he played for the Celtics
he's like a redhead he's six nine he's
huge but I think he looks like uh Will
Ferrell but actually was an MB NBA
player yeah so easy to make fun of but I
think he was like okay right or was he
always yeah he he was okay but then like
it was okay but he was he didn't take
himself too seriously and over time you
know like he had a kind of a few years
where he actually played but most of his
career he's on the bench as a scrub and
uh yeah yeah bar shops his nickname Kobe
was the Black Mamba he started calling
himself The White Mamba and so you know
he was a goofy dude who was basically a
benchwarmer for like the last whatever
seven years of his career uh but was a
great you know great locker room
presence and and you know a warm body so
people kept him around and I think at
one point he called himself I don't know
if it's a joke or what the worst player
in the NBA obviously was a joke but
anyway after he retired so I guess he
retired from the NBA somewhat recently
ish but he's still six nine and athletic
and whatever or athletic for uh you know
he's a basketball player but compared to
the other guys he wasn't like that
athletic but he starts playing Rec
leagues and like he would score you know
record leads like at the YMCA and on uh
playgrounds and he scores like 60 points
a game you know just crushing these guys
and he doesn't like brag about it too
much but then like online at one point
he mentions like yeah I got 60 points
last night at my reckley and then just
people online just start chirping at him
hard and they're like dude you suck I
could beat you or you I don't even know
how you made it in the NBA you know yada
yada yada they start chirping at him and
he goes wait a minute no I maybe suck
compared to Derrick Rose but I don't
suck compared to any of you guys and so
he starts doing this tour where he goes
to like uh all these basketball courts
he goes I want to go to the the the the
hoodess of the hood basketball court I
want to go to the best YMCA I wanna I'll
go all around the country and he starts
doing this and he crushes these guys and
he challenges people he says come play
me one-on-one do you think I suck come
play me one-on-one yeah and he and he
destroys them and there's he he's like
I'm not even gonna do this for social
media but some people recorded a couple
of these things that he would beat them
like 10 nothing he was like I let him
get one point just to figure out what
they're gonna do but I just destroy
these guys and he's got this awesome
quote that he goes he said this to like
one of the kids it was like an 18 year
old kid who like plays against him in
any any and he crushes this kid he goes
let's get something straight I'm closer
to LeBron than you are to me and I
thought
I read that and I go this is the
greatest thing I've ever heard this is
awesome it's such a good story and he
called it the scallenge and I thought it
was so good it just shows you know
there's levels to Greatness yeah there's
levels to this I think it's the perfect
the perfect takeaway from that and also
he's hilarious he is so good
um I don't remember this by the way we
were when we did our our camp MFM get
away
um the the guy who came to train us he's
he trains like a bunch of NBA stars so
he trains Kyrie Irving he's changed Trey
young and so he was there and his wife
is in the WNBA and uh she's like one of
the best players in the WNBA we're
talking about the WNBA and how like
their you know the players are awesome
but they also don't get like high
viewership it's like not like the league
doesn't do that well it's kind of like
subsidized by the NBA it kind of loses
money but you know it it's good overall
for the sport for there to be a women's
league and so we were like yeah well we
had kind of a impromptu brainstorm of
like the same thing everyone says which
is can I beat her up you know like it's
like when everyone says
wait a bunch of drunk and he gets that
Buffalo Wild Wings are watching like
Rosemary Eunice and like these female
UFC fighters everyone thinks it can I
kick her ass yeah what would happen if I
fought her yeah exactly uh so basically
we did a brainstorm like what would you
do to get ratings up or to like if you
were to launch a different women's
league like how would you get people
interested because the problem is I
think I saw this this crazy Tick Tock it
was like some team whoever won the
championship last year I have no idea
maybe it's like the Atlanta Dream or
something like that and they came home
to do their parade in the city and it
literally just looked like you know if I
walk to my bus stop here and there's
like three people kind of loitering
around there's like a bum and then you
know that was the parade there was
nobody there for the parade and the the
team was going down on the bus and it
was just like other people were like why
is this what is this why is this bus
here what oh do you guys play a sport I
didn't really realize that so this is
Tick Tock that went viral making fun of
it
um and yeah the idea that that we all
landed on was
basically the three or four three four
five best players should basically go on
tour like it's the and one mixtape tour
and go City to city and challenge you
know any five you know go play pickup
with any with dudes at any of these and
live stream that
um or like cut that into clips of them
basically punking punking guys yeah like
beating guys who think they could beat
them and uh yeah put some respect on
their name so so that was kind of the
marketing idea but yeah to our if the
CMO of the WMA is listening you're
welcome dude I love these challenges
there's another one where like uh when
you're watching running running's not a
popular sport but I love it it's my
favorite sport to watch uh next to the
UFC and the people were like they're not
that they're like a two-hour Marathon do
you remember that when the guy elude he
ran two hours and he just looks so
smooth he looks closer to an animal than
he does a human like his body is just
like he just you know running 100 miles
a week for probably 20 years he's just
like his you look at his Cavs and you're
like I I can't believe that you and I
are like the same we're both humans it's
just it's not even fair he looks
graceful when he runs he looks beautiful
and he doesn't look that fast and so
they put a treadmill at the same speed
and they go here's here's because he's
dealing with ease he's doing it with
ease and he does it for two hours and
they go see if you can do this for 15
seconds and they have this treadmill and
like people can't do it for just 20
seconds they can't even run that speed
it's basically like four minutes and 30
seconds a mile which is like I don't
know would that be like 60 miles from
sprinting for me yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like a Sprint and um it's a Sprint
for most people and uh it was really
funny no one could keep up with it so I
love these like that's actually one of
the tenets of making content viral which
is it made you have to make something
made to stick and you can make it stick
by comparing it to real tangible things
that everyone can understand and when
you put one of these treadmills at that
speed you're like oh I can't keep up
with that for 10 seconds let alone two
hours totally totally somebody said this
about the Olympics they go the Olympics
there should be one civilian in every
event and just a normal fit guy from the
gym and it should just be like just as a
baseline comparison here's the average
person and you know here's even like an
above average person and then here's the
Olympians like let them all just let
them line up in lane 11. and see what
happens dude I would love that I would
love that I have uh I've got I've got a
big meaty topic what do you have all
right so
I this is a story of a
multi-millioned easily multi-million pop
Ben type in the chat do the calculation
how much I I lost doing this let's see I
would have invested at a company at 5
million and it's now a three billion ish
company
um so you know I I basically turned I
missed out on a chance to probably turn
something like 25k into tens of millions
of dollars yeah
um okay so here's what happened but it's
kind of there's kind of some some
interesting things baked into this so
it's not just that oh I missed a big
deal uh everybody misses misses
opportunities this is uh an interesting
one so back in 2015 uh which is kind of
when we met
um I was not a angel investor but I
liked the idea I thought it sounded cool
I was a founder of of a company uh and I
was making I think
100 160 Grand a year it's 160 Grand a
year
back then you told me you're making 160
and I was like oh you're the richest
person I know I remember you told me
you're making 150 000 I was like oh my
God
yeah I I remember I was like man find a
find somebody who looks at me the way
Sam looks at me right now by the way
that Sam looks at my pay stub and so
um so yeah I I was making 160 a year but
in in California you know you're kind of
after taxes now you're at like 110
you're netting you know and then you pay
for life it's pretty expensive blah blah
blah you don't save much so I didn't
have much of a bankroll but I like the
idea of being an angel investor and
people because our office was so dope
when a Founder would come they would
think that I'm a lot richer than I was
but just because our office was so
fancy which was only fancy because our
main investor owned the building and
decked it out for himself and like
that's why the office was so fancy it
had nothing to do with me so anyways I
um
I meet this kid we're building a product
and I meet this kid he's 13 years old
and he uses our app every day our app
was like a clubhouse type of app he used
to use it every day after school come
home use the app and he's hanging out in
the Silicon Valley chat rooms and we're
like dude you should be like going and
go try to have a kiss like you know that
should be your mission not like sitting
in on this room talking about raising
your series a and
um and so two things happened one he's
like dude I want to come work with you
guys whatever we're like dude you're in
Middle School like I can't your parents
are gonna kill me I can't help you work
for us if I go here's
here's what you can do he goes I want to
be a scout for you I said okay go ahead
okay it'd be a scout for me he goes
um he goes he goes what do you want me
to do I go every week
I want you to send me a company that you
think is awesome and that you think I
should invest in and just write why you
think I should invest and send me the
company now I have zero hope or really
even zero plan to read this email at the
time I'm just basically giving this kid
a homework assignment I'm like yeah this
will help you
think and most likely this is going to
be too much work for you you might do it
once you might do it twice but you're
gonna give up by the third time for sure
so I give him this homework assignment
very first company he sends me he is a
company called apply board and so here's
uh
this was the second this is sorry this
is the second week hey Sean here's the
second company I want to introduce apply
board what they do they help
International students find the right
University for themselves and apply
there on their behalf they have 11
schools contracted to pay them a
commission for ever uh for a student
that gets that signs up and they have 14
more schools in the funnel they have
over 1500 students signed up 160
000 Facebook likes and this is all with
ten dollars in paid marketing this is
actually pretty interesting right like
that's actually a kind of a a really
good analysis and that's you know simple
two lines so I'm like wow this kid's 13
he's like you know he's this is a good
find and he's explained it well he goes
why you should invest now this is where
he got a little off but that's okay he
goes they started four years ago with
offline Consulting and then pivoted into
a software business they know the space
well they have four co-founders they
have a very very diverse skill set blah
blah
um
they have an algorithm something
something and he says
um their customer acquisition costs only
a few dollars the LTV is a thousand so
they have sustainable growth uh he goes
I'm trying to correct my shots so that
one day I could hit the bullseye for you
if you have any feedback on the company
I would love to hear it because the
first one I didn't even respond I said
like this is bad
um so this is his second one and I'm
like you know what this is actually
pretty good I'm gonna take this meeting
so guy is in San Francisco he comes to
my office love him super Charming this
guy Martin
um you you've probably met like a bunch
of these guys who are like there's
something that's really just like uh
I don't know charismatic or charming
about dudes from like you know Israel or
something like that like anyone is like
Israel Persian turkey there's like it's
like there's just so goddamn Charming
like they're just dripping with sauce
and what it's Cliff's company effortless
what's our booty Cliff Cliff W uh Cliff
uh Weitzman yeah um it's the audio one I
I think he's uh Middle Eastern I met him
uh when when he was just starting and I
was like it he had oh he's Israeli
actually uh he had that same Vibe and in
the office I go what's interesting about
you or something and he goes I can do a
backflip I go all right well
yeah my friends yeah I said uh all right
well uh move that chair over there's
enough room here go do it and he did a
backflip in the middle of my office and
uh his company now speechify it's it's
in the Unicorn territory and I didn't
invest in it but that like he had that
same Charisma when he came to my office
he lit up the room I should have I
should have known better yeah he's got
amazing energy and uh and so yeah this
is the so so he so I meet this guy he's
got the Israeli swag I'm loving it and
then and again I have never at this
point I've never Angel invest in a
company but I'm like this seems like a
great idea and what they're why this is
a great idea for people to know it's
kind of a effed up part of the system
which is colleges in the U.S
just have like surge pricing for
international students so it's basically
like if I'm a if I'm a state resident I
get like cheaper tuition at State
schools okay but if I'm a U.S resident I
pay you know what I thought is full
price so maybe I'll pay 25k uh to go to
school at this place but an
international student will have to pay
two or three times more than that so
they'll pay 50 to 75 000 for the same
exact thing they just charge them more
it's kind of insane I don't really know
even how they are able to justify this
but they do
and um and so you remember in San
Francisco University was that what it's
called University of San Francisco I I
dated a girl that went like had ties
there and I remember walking around
campus and it was only Chinese students
and it's and it's not even good schools
like Universe San Francisco or USF or
whatever it's not even that good of a
school and so it's actually it's
actually a bit of a trick it's like um
International students just want to come
to America they can't differentiate
between uh you know University of Utah
and you know
um you know Colombia or whatever like
these different schools they don't know
the the lay of the land that well they
don't know that the school's in the
middle of nowhere they don't know that
it's not actually considered that
prestigious or whatever it is it's just
expensive uh so it's actually a lot of
these other schools that really take
advantage of this and have a huge
percentage of their population coming
from International which makes up a
disproportionate amount of Revenue so
that's kind of like why the schools are
interested so they went to him and they
were like yeah we'll give you three
thousand dollars if you can get somebody
to sign up he's like three thousand
dollars oh that's pretty good and I
think now they take a lot more than I
think that now they take you know ten
percent or something of the of the
overall tuition so it's gone up since
then but um anyways so he pitches and
I'm like dude I just get yeah I get
caught up I like the idea I love this
guy's personality I'm like I'm in
he's like you're in I'm in he said
fantastic I haven't really talked to
anybody else yet uh so I don't know all
the round details I said brother I'm in
and uh he's like all right love it
you're you're the first guy met in
Silicon Valley you're my champion on
this and I thought I'm the first guy
he's been oh wait hold on
I didn't really want to be the first guy
in like you know first at the dance
floor is kind of like not not exactly
the position to be in so then he goes on
tour he goes starts pitching people and
he starts coming back to me with and he
he's a nice dude he's honest guys trust
me he says man they're saying no because
of this and I'm like oh these guys are
idiots don't worry about them they don't
get it next one they came back they said
no because of this and as by the third
one I'm like maybe I should have been
saying no so I start to doubt my uh my
conviction in this thing but I'm still
like brother I told you I'm in so I'm in
and uh anyways it takes them a little
time if the edit the story is you backed
out on him and you were calling him
brother
in fact I think he was calling me
brother because that was like you know
it's like the khabib thing where they
just they just say brother a lot uh you
just knifed him in the back well I
didn't actually knife him in the back I
don't know I don't know exactly what I
don't know I don't remember exactly how
it played out but I definitely uh worst
out so so basically takes them a little
time to raise the round he eventually
does get the round together and I'm
supposed to write a 25k check not even
like some crazy amount of money but to
me at that time that was like
it's like all right well that's kind of
like my entire like savings for this
year is going to go to this one random
Israeli guys company all right uh you
know I I could lose this but I would
really hate to lose this and I start
thinking about you know am I ready for
this I don't know and so I kind of just
I don't back out but I don't uh from
what I remember I didn't back out but I
didn't reach back out either and so I
think he probably emailed me once I was
like yeah okay let me know when it's
time and then he probably emailed me
like three or four weeks later I was
like yo it's time and I just like didn't
reply to that thing and I I don't think
anything really happened but anyways
long story short I don't invest
um fast forward you know five years I
get an email from that same kid saroosh
and sarush is like hey remember this
email yeah plyboard's a unicorn now huh
and uh you know what do you know curious
what you think about that and I was like
I think I was an idiot and I I think it
was a total idiot and there's actually a
few kind of like takeaways in this for
me so the few takeaways are
one
um don't be a wuss if you say you're
gonna do something just do it that's
just a lesson for myself and I think you
know for most people uh yourself
included that's that's rarely a problem
for me that's more of a problem
second
um I actually think I was correct that I
was not ready to be Angel Investing at
the time
um and so I should have either could
have done like a five thousand dollar
Check Yes exactly so what I should have
done is I should have said all right
look
I don't have the bankroll to place 20
bets which is kind of what you'll need
you need 20 to 30 bets for you know
Angel Investing to work and so it's like
you know I don't I don't realistically I
do not have the bankroll to do this
but that's okay that doesn't mean I
don't do what I want it means I got to
be resourceful and find a way so either
let me come in at a smaller check size
that make it's my version of you know if
an angel investor writes 25k when they
have five million dollars then I need to
write the proportional check for me and
see what happens or I should have gone
to somebody and said
hey I actually found this deal I think
it's really good you have the money uh
which is what I did later with Lambda
school it was like hey I like this
company uh they haven't really raised
much money yet it's not proven but like
I think it's worth a shot and I
convinced somebody else to write the
check and give me some carry so that's
really what I should have done to make
this happen but at the time my fear
overrode my like
um you know the the uh not even ego the
fear overrode my like uh ability to
think like from Earth just think like
with a clear head and say okay well
sounds like there's just a little
obstacle here and let's figure out how
we're gonna get around it a lot of
people are embarrassed they're saying
like well can I do five thousand like I
remember doing a deal I I did a deal for
15 or 25 000 when I didn't have a lot of
money thankfully on paper it's turned
into a bit but I remember thinking like
I want to ask them if I could do 5K but
I don't want to look like a punk right
yeah so so I think I I should have found
a way and that's I think uh has been a
common theme in my life which is like a
lot of good opportunities come my way
and I say I don't have the time I don't
have the money I don't have the skill I
don't have whatever and I rule it out
even though objectively I'm like this is
a great opportunity and the real answer
is
find a way to get the time or find
somebody who does have the time find a
way to get the money or find somebody
who has the money to help you out right
like do do one of those things to get
there uh and this is not like a small
thing like just doing the difference
between doing that and not doing that
would have been again tens of millions
of dollars in this case when in the
result case where it worked out so
that's one takeaway the second is this
guy's saroosh is like now become a
general strategy for me which is I
always want to have like
I don't know four or five people who are
kind of like way
it's like an anti-mentor all right like
you know it's a mentee or something like
that right it's like I want to have
people that are young hungry and
ignorant and naive uh but that's an
asset for them because they're young and
hungry uh I want to have them more in my
Orbit and I need to find some excuse to
have them in my Orbit and hang out with
them and hear what they think is
interesting and meet their friends and
whatever like that is
um you know I think that is an actual
strategy that most people miss out on
everybody wants to to sort of climb up
they're like oh how do I meet the person
who's done more than me or is more
successful than me has more money than
me whatever and they're focused
constantly on like reaching up and
trying to like pull themselves up and
instead I found so much benefit out of
just having a crew a small crew of like
18 to 21 year olds that I'm like okay
you guys just think differently to me
you're worried about different things
and um you're excited about different
things than me how do I have that in my
life in some way and so that's actually
become a more core strategy do you do
anything like that yeah so listen to
this so we had this kid by the way thank
you for not making like an uh Epstein
joke I felt like I was treading I was
like what you need is like 14 year old
dudes that you hang out with all the
time it's like yeah no I I so I'm 33 I'm
just now hitting the age where I'm no
longer the youngest guy in the room and
I'm just hitting the age where I've got
15 years or so of experience and I'm
seeing younger people and I'm like oh
you're full of energy you're going to do
something but you're making an air here
and I'm just gonna let I'm just going to
watch you make that air because it's
good for you I'm just now getting to the
point where I'm able to be a little wise
and I'm seeing the importance of
surrounding ourselves with young people
here's an example
a year ago Sean and I did this thing
where we offered five thousand dollars
to someone who made a tick tock video
from our
podcast and shared it one kid in
particular his name was Michael at the
time he made these videos that reached
tens of millions of people for us and we
gave him the five grand and I went to
email him and I was like dude you should
do this full time and I asked him what
his email and it was like you know
Michael at University of michigan.edu
and I was like wait who are you he goes
yeah I just recorded this in my dorm
room I'm like oh you're gonna be you're
on to something you're gonna be a
superstar just start throwing this into
a company turns into a company uh I
guess r5k was his first money he makes
tens of thousands of dollars a month
eventually sells it to morning Brew uh
Michael what's Michael's last name I
don't even know it's a can yeah
and he comes over to my house and uses
the studio and I just he'll mean Sarah
will be in the kitchen and I'll just I
go Mike come out to the kitchen have a
coffee with me and me and Sarah won't
say a word and we'll just let him talk
and I'm just like I'm just here just
because he's 22 maybe I'm like my kid
should have some chocolate milk yeah
yeah you want some hot cocoa lollipop
yeah sit on my lap too while you're at
it and like he just talks and about 60
of the stuff that he says is nonsense 40
absolute nonsense not just him anybody
who fits this category you have to
literally just immediately throw away 60
of the words but what I say to him I go
Michael most of what you're saying is
[__] and I think you might know it
but look here's the deal even a blind
squirrel finds a nut a nut once in a
while keep on swinging you'll hit a home
run soon because you're swinging you're
in the game and I appreciate that about
you and if you ever want to know what
you're saying is [__] just ask me
and I'll tell you but I'm not gonna call
you yeah I'm gonna let you get away with
it all because I I like I like this
gumption and he tweeted something the
other day that was hilarious he tweeted
got bad news just got back from the
chiropractor they said the chip on my
shoulder is permanent
how funny is that
and I was like this is why you're gonna
make something of yourself now you might
ruin it by saying dub stuff and you're
gonna cost yourself a whole lot of money
and you're gonna have a lot of headache
throughout the years until you learn to
be calmer but you know he was feeling
good about that line too when he tweeted
but I appreciate that this is a young
kid so I have I had he moved to Austin I
invite him over all the time and I go
just talk man just just just talk I want
to hear what you got to say and he's
telling me like and I'm just like
learning about what like the younger
generation feels about this and that and
he's like yeah we're gonna he's like he
has a birthday party coming up on
Saturday and we're taking some like new
weird version of uber I don't even know
what it is like a party bus company I
don't even know what it is but he's like
this is what all this is what we're all
using I was like all right cool I'm in I
just want to experience this stuff so
yes long story short I totally I am
experiencing this where I have young
people around me sounds weird but let's
get past that
strategy is a real strategy and uh and
actually this is my reminder to myself I
need to refresh my my young Bloods are
now like 24 to 25 and Rich they're like
made it like okay so Michael is one
example
um the other guys who set up our initial
studios here and then created that uh
agency clipped they've they do over a
million dollars a year in Revenue off
their off their thing and now their
their content is going going nuts their
short form videos are going nuts like
millions of views
um and I had to like reprimand reprimand
Henry all the time I was like hey Henry
just so you know you shouldn't talk like
this when you're in this meeting or
something and then eventually I was like
you know I'm not going to give them
advice I'm just going to let them learn
but I saw the same thing where I'm like
you're making a bunch of mistakes but
you're taking a ton of swings you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna hit uh
the kid I talked about saroosh uh
probably has more money than me now from
crypto the guy has made an absolute
killing in crypto over the last few
years and so done done incredibly well
uh the guy who was my intern to start
this podcast uh ishan who was just like
doing the video editing and like created
the initial brand name and all that
stuff invest all of his money into like
a short stock a short position on a
penny no not a short not a short one he
he went all in he took basically he had
like 100 Grand safe up after a couple
years of working for me and then for for
a friend I introduced him to and he took
the hundred grand and he just bought
there was a stock that got delisted on a
stock exchange so all the shareholders
were like damn it what do we do with the
stock that we can't trade anymore it's
like illiquid and so he bought it all
for like 10 cents on the dollar being
like I don't know I still believe and
then that ran up to be worth a few
million dollars uh his his 100K
basically turned into like a two to five
million dollar stake at that time now I
think down a little bit but
um there's articles about him and the
Australian post or whatever now and I'm
like dude this is crazy who and another
one Steve Bartlett uh hired Steve when I
when he was uh 18 19 years old maybe
maybe that's a little maybe maybe he's
20 at the time
um
and I was like this guy again just
dripping with swag and I was like I just
want to be around this guy this guy's
like cool I don't know he wears like
rings and he like says words I don't
know and like for some reason he his
tweets go viral uh I don't know like
mine don't so like what does this guy
know and sure enough
ends up creating this social media
agency ends up taking it public has this
great podcast that's super popular he's
a shark on the Shark Tank of Europe like
this guy's like now he's like he's the
black garyvee now and so it's like
there's a it's like dude that's I just
thought of six in the last 15 seconds
like I don't even there might be even
more that I'm not even remembering that
or like come from the same batch and uh
I need to I need a new batch my little
personal YC this is good that you're
talking about this so I was talking to a
friend yesterday so uh producer Ben you
can leave all this live but you're gonna
have to uh bleep out what I'm about to
say but I want Shawn to know what it is
so um my friend I was talking to
he said uh he he just mentioned it we
were talking about something totally
different and he was like yeah you know
like you know I made 30 million dollars
from an angel investment and um yeah you
know so this is how I found my
accountant I did this this because I was
asking him for a good accountant and I
was like
like I'd be the rewind sound I was like
like you know scratching the record
reverse tell me about this like he goes
yeah basically I was uh you know like
president of like a smallish startup
that wasn't doing so well and a 22 year
old kid who worked for me he quit to
start a company and I was you know
frustrated at first but like he was real
promising and so I invested 25 thousand
dollars
uh at a three million dollar valuation
the company went public like a year or
two ago and it was a 15 billion dollar
valuation it was called a market cap it
was called This is the part you got to
bleep out it was called
you know that company no but okay it's a
boring
nothing special like B2B whatever
um and uh he he's like yeah I had 75 000
at the time uh when I was running my
first startup I didn't have a lot of
money but I decided to invest all of it
into startups and I did it in sizes of
10 and 25 000 and that one check that I
did of twenty five thousand dollars it
turned into 30 million dollars
um and and I was like are you kidding me
he goes yeah basically like I knew this
kid was strong and I wanted to be part
of just whatever he was in I wanted to
surround myself with young people and I
thought he was promising and uh in fact
it it worked out really well and I made
so much money off of this one deal and
he goes and then the other one he said
made like a 10x return as well
and you just got super lucky on that one
and it totally worked out so it's crazy
story and I'm like well I've invested in
a bunch of companies I'm late for that
to happen that'd be nice yeah exactly
what part do I do for the 30 billion is
there a line for that am I in the right
line yeah
yeah so it worked out it's a crazy story
um that was good um all right I had
another one but let's let's save it for
the next uh let's save the next episode
because it's getting a little long now
all right that's the Pod I think that
was a banger uh we forgot to remind
people if you made it this far there is
a gentleman's agreement this content
that you're listening to it is not free
we're like one of the only places on
YouTube actually where the content's not
free
you have to pay what do you have to pay
with
that's your cue Sean oh oh I was
enthralled I was ready for you to just
keep going I thought you were on one go
ahead keep going you have to pay
something in order to listen to this
channel if you've listened to more than
one thing you have to do me a favor go
to the YouTube page and click subscribe
because that like helps us or you know
what what I'm gonna ask people to do if
you're listening to this on like apple
or um Spotify share this share it on
Twitter LinkedIn all that stuff and and
we're even so you listen to us I just
spent hours on This research by the way
and right you spent 15 million dollars
of lost money in order to make this
content to tell that story yep
in front of you so uh
subscribe to the channel yeah this is
not this is not this channel is not free
you have to click subscribe on YouTube
because we're trying to build up a
YouTube and you have to click subscribe
and follow on the spot podcast by the
way what I like people go in the
comments on YouTube and they just say
they honored the gentleman's agreement
and I go to each one and I just say from
handshakes from handshakes to you from
handshake to you too so that's what you
have to do and by the way I read every
comment on those YouTube things all
right we're out of here
[Music]